-That feel good to get
a standing ovation?
-It sure does.
Thank you very much.
-Welcome back!
-Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I love having you on.
-Thank you.
-You're a friend to
"The Tonight Show."
You've been on
"The Tonight Show"
with Jack Paar.
-Yes.
-You've been on with Johnny
Carson, Jay Leno, and now me.
-And you.
-Yeah.
And I'm so happy that
you're here.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Oh, please. I'm honored.
You were given
a Lifetime Achievement Award
by the American Film Institute.
-I was, last week.
-Last week?
[ Applause ]
It's quite an honor.
-It's a huge honor, and I was
absolutely thrilled.
And they spoiled me, and so many
people came that night.
-Your speech was so touching
and so cool, I thought.
-Oh, thank you.
-It wasn't about you,
which I thought was interesting.
You didn't make it about you.
You wanted to thank the crew.
-Well, you know,
I actually said that
nobody acknowledges,
except in the credits
that run by far too fast,
as well well know.
-Yes.
-Especially on TV.
I wish something could be
done about that.
I just wanted to acknowledge
everybody in the studio,
and there are hundreds of people
behind the camera,
and nobody ever recognizes them,
so I wanted to do that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's true.
-There's so many people
that make the film
and make everyone look good.
You said that there was
a set designer,
or a painter, maybe?
-It's a true story.
I was driving home one day
off the lot
at 20th Century Fox,
and I was finishing
a long day of shooting
on "The Sound of Music."
And I passed a gentleman, as I
got to the back gate of the lot,
which was the quick way home,
for me.
I passed a gentleman
who was painting
in a sort of open shed.
And he smiled at me as I waited
for the gate
to open at the back,
and I rolled down my window
and I said,
"You're working a bit late
tonight, aren't you?"
And he came over
and talked to me,
and he told me how proud he was
and how long he'd been
working at the studio.
And he said, almost boasting,
"You know, I've painted sets
for Marilyn Monroe
and Jack Lemmon
and Shirley MacLaine."
And I suddenly thought, my God.
That's what made me want to
acknowledge everybody,
because he was so thrilled
to be a part of film,
and I don't think anybody
knew he was there.
-Yeah.
-Exactly, and this business,
it's just great to
acknowledge everybody.
-Well, it takes a lot of people.
It's all about -- it's here,
everywhere, about collaboration.
-So you did this, and
immediately after the ceremony,
you flew to your granddaughter's
high school graduation.
-Yes, the next day.
-And you nailed it, and she's
going to study theater and film.
-Yep, she's going to
Sarah Lawrence,
and she's going to study
theater and film
and literature,
and all the rest.
-Do you give advice?
-A little bit, but she's got
some kind of savvy
that I don't know where it --
I mean, I do know
where it comes from, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
But she seems to know
a lot already.
-Yeah.
-She's very, very smart,
and very talented.
-Do your grandchildren realize
that their grandmother
is Mary Poppins?
-Well, now they do, but --
I think.
-Yeah.
When my grandson, my lovely
young girl's brother,
was very young,
he was about 4, I guess,
and they were showing "Mary
Poppins" at a birthday party
that he went to.
When his mother came
to pick him up,
he was standing this close
to the television,
looking terribly puzzled.
[ Laughter ]
And my daughter bent down
and said, "Do you know
who that lady is?"
And he went, "Uh-uh."
And she said, "Is it maybe
somebody that we know
very well?"
"Uh-uh."
And she said, "Is it maybe
Granny Jules?"
And he went, "Oh, yes!"
[ Laughter ]
He was thrilled.
-Isn't that great?
-But the best part was,
the next day,
when I went over to the house
to see him, he said,
"Hello, Granny Jules."
And it was with such
a knowing look,
and "I know what you do."
[ Laughter ]
It was adorable. You know with
kids, it's so sweet.
Yeah.
-When people come up to you
on the street, do they recognize
you for different films?
-They certainly do these days,
but it's interesting.
It depends what age they are,
Jimmy.
If it's a young kid, it's,
"Oh, I loved you
in 'Princess Diaries.'"
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But...
But if it's an older lady
or a granny or somebody
like that,
it's "I adored you in
'Sound of Music,'" or so on.
And it just depends.
-Yeah.
-You have such a great career,
but it is interesting that
probably the number one question
at all the interviews
I've watched you do recently is,
everyone asks you, "Is there
gonna be 'Princess Diaries 3'?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Honestly, I doubt it,
because I'm that much older,
and Annie's that much older.
Annie Hathaway,
who was so lovely.
-Yeah.
-There was talk about it
many, many years ago,
but I think it's gone
too far now.
I'd be thrilled
if it would happen,
but I can't think what
the story would be now.
-Yeah.
Let's talk about
another blockbuster,
a children's hit.
"Minions: The Rise of Gru."
-Yes!
[ Applause ]
-It's out July 1st.
-Aren't those Minions adorable?
Don't you love them?
-How do they do it?
It's so genius.
-There's one that just
says, "Hello,"
something like that,
and he's adorable.
-He's so cute, yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-I saw it with my girls,
they're 8 and 7,
and they loved it.
Do you like playing a villain?
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
Gru's mum is one of
the worst characters
you could possibly imagine.
She's the worst role model
for a mother.
She's terrible to Gru,
and it was a delight to
get my teeth into it,
I have to admit.
-[ Laughing ] You nailed it.
You nailed it.
[ Applause ]
It's so perfect.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Julie Andrews in
"Minions: The Rise of Gru."
-Oh, you angel.
-Take a look.
-Thank you.
-[ Cackling ]
-Mom?
-Blahhh.
♪♪
Blahhh.
Blahhhh!
-What?
Mom, who is this sweaty guy?
He's stinking up the house.
I thought you were
cooking cabbage.
-He's my new guru.
-Blehhh.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Blahhh!
-Bllll!
-Tell your weird buddies they
better start
pulling their weight
around here,
or I'm kicking them out!
They are killing
my mellow vibes!
-Uh...
-Bleh-bleh-bleh-bleh.
-Hey! I heard that.
[ Laughing ]
-That's right!
Julie Andrews,
ladies and gentlemen!
"Minions: The Rise of Gru"
is in theaters July 1st.
-Thank you so much.
-We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."